yes change things forever welcome back
to the final review in the six part
series I've been involved with with the
schmoes no talking about the Dark Knight
this one been waiting for us want to
talk about this movie now some of my
newer viewers may not know that the
poster directly behind me is the Dark
Knight I adore this movie this is one of
my favorite movies ever made I love the
Dark Knight it's just everything about
it was exactly what I wanted it to be
I'll never forget the first night I saw
this movie I wasn't seeing screenings at
that time I wasn't doing anything on
YouTube and I went to the midnight
premiere it was Thursday I was with a
group of my friends we got there like an
hour early and there was a line in the
parking lot out into the parking lot
almost hitting the street we had
reserved our tickets online and we were
still worried if we were going to be
able to get in or not but the theater
had reserved nearly every auditorium in
that theater to show The Dark Knight I
got in that theater and every single
seat was filled I have never sensed it
been to a movie unless it was an
advanced screening in which every seat
was filled and by the time the Joker
took that guy's head and slammed it into
that pencil and the entire audience
applauded I knew I was in for something
special
see to them they're just a freak
like me one of the best things that no
one did for this movie happened in
Batman Begins
he saved the most iconic Batman villain
not for the first film not for his big
introduction but for the next film he
let you get into that world he made you
invested in the characters in Gotham and
everything that he was creating and now
that you're invested in it let's bring
out the big guns the Joker Heath Ledger
knock this right out of the park
dear Lord Heath Ledger was goodness
moving to this day that was one of the
best performances ever given by an actor
it's so sad what happened to him it's
it's seriously like I still think about
it and it makes me so sad because this
performance is honestly the performance
of a lifetime I still remember that
scene where he grabs gamble by the head
and sticks a knife in his mouth I was on
the edge of my seat I was like oh I was
not expecting anything like this in a
Batman movie it was just so it was scary
like I was actually like what are we
gonna see Christian Bale is Batman here
like a lot of people make fun of the
voice and yes the voice is extremely
exaggerated but I like it I like it I
think it's really entertaining they can
add something to the movie every other
actor or there was like a Batman except
for George Clooney of course I freeze
I'm Batman
I like the voice I do I like it what are
we got nothing no name no other alias
clothing is custom nothing in his
pockets with knives and lint another
thing I love about this movie is Gary
Oldman as Gordon he is fantastic
I mean I honestly think that there are
so many performances in this movie that
because of heat Ledger's amazing
performance are overlooked namely Gary
Oldman's and Aaron Eckhart's as Harvey
Dent Aaron Eckhart blew me away in this
movie this is till this day still his
best performance I've ever seen him give
his role was so pivotal on him taking it
seriously and the filmmakers taking it
seriously this transformation that
happens with him the last time we saw
two-face was Batman forever okay and we
don't like to forget about that I'm sure
he basically has the exact same ideals
as Batman except he wants to do it in
more legal terms he wants to make Gotham
a good City again and that's why Bruce
Wayne takes an interest in him and kind
of Usher's him along through this but
the same time the Joker is there and
what is so great about this villain is
he understands
morals of Batman he knows that Batman
doesn't want to kill and he keeps
setting up all these different things
that's going to cause Batman to want to
do that or have to do that to get out of
the situation he creates moral dilemmas
for people and for Batman in this movie
and that's why he's such a good villain
because he finds the weaknesses of each
person that he wants to attack in some
way and he exploits them evening come
why another thing that's so great about
the Joker in this movie is the fact that
he actually makes sense he's doing
horrible things but you can understand
why he's doing that
to illustrate the scene in the hospital
when the Joker is talking to Harvey Dent
and he says if tomorrow I say that like
a gangbanger will get shot or a
truckload of soldiers will be blown up
nobody panics because it's all part of a
plan but if I say then one little old
mayor will die well then everyone loses
their minds and I remember the first
time I saw the movie I was thinking yeah
that actually makes sense yeah that
that's scary but he's right he's not
just some mindless lunatic maniac just
out there doing whatever he wants he
understands some of the things that is
wrong with society and he's trying to in
a very bad way fix that the rioting
there is just flawless it's fantastic
and that's why he is the perfect villain
for Batman this movie illustrates so
well one of the Joker's last lines in
the film is this he says this is what
happens when an unstoppable force meets
an immovable object and that is exactly
why these characters work so well I want
to talk about one of the best scenes in
this movie the interrogation scene that
is some of the best confrontational
dialogue ever put the film
where is he
particular dying would you have me to
injure you
the app cost you can make the choice
that no one else will face and it
illustrates my point even more as the
Batman is trying to prove that what
Joker is doing is wrong and it is wrong
what he's doing the way he's going about
doing it the Joker is able to give
completely logical reasons as to why
he's doing what he's doing and they make
sense they both make sense you can
actually watch The Dark Knight and
understand exactly where each character
is coming from this movie is close to
perfect as movies can get I adore The
Dark Knight is such an excellent movie
everything from the visuals to the music
Hans Zimmer and James Newton Howard
score Christian Bale's Batman Michael
Caine Morgan Freeman Gary Oldman Maggie
Gyllenhaal Aaron Eckhart Heath Ledger
everyone in this movie is flawless this
is an excellent film I love it it's one
of my all-time favorite movies in a
course you know the Dark Knight gets an
A+ all right now onto the schmoes for
their review of The Dark Knight why do I
want to kill me we are talking about the
Dark Knight if you have been checking
out our series that we've been doing on
our channel recently we just did Batman
Begins that was his favorite yeah this
series what are you the guy from Krank
hang out we've been playing Batman ping
pong on our channel crystal egg machine
we're back on Chris Rock miss Jana
because we're talking about the last
Batman Billy they buddy seen so far The
Dark Knight starring Christian Bale's
Batman and Heath Ledger and an
oscar-winning performance as la Joker
not only is this my favorite Batman
movie this is one of my favorite movies
of all time okay often it's it's yeah I
it was definitely in there just so many
movies I've seen I even put in a top we
don't care about you that much you son
of a alright now the thing is why do I
love this movie am i drinking the
kool-aid the Nolan kool-aid sure
whatever I'm drinking it I love it and
I'm getting fat off of it because it's a
good movie and there's so much this is
the movie that really made me go okay
this guy this guy's legit you know as a
fat kid I think I'd go on a coin I
didn't realize that calories that mean
but thinks it made me fat here's the
coil you're drinking is it actually
looks like the Joker had a little bit
too much cooler because he's got a
really creepy kool-aid moustache in this
Heath Ledger as the Joker is kind of
what really elevated this movie to the
next level far as hype is concerned
because he tragically died after
shooting the movie
before it came out so everybody's
wondering what's his Joker gonna be like
and ended up winning the guy of
posthumous Oscar custom
creepy voice - it's terrible Joker but
the fact of the matter that wasn't great
it wasn't great but I stopped and I
bailed on it but it's it was the
different type of joke that we saw and
what was so great about it
don't you make fun of my no I'm gonna
say you did the opposite of what Heath
Ledger did you made it on it well Heath
Ledger committed so hard to this
character that's a good point this movie
opens up and you don't see him you don't
know what's going on all you know is you
were back into a moment almost like the
95 Michael Mann film heat is what it
felt like that kind of slow building
music the way that they rushed in robbed
the bank and then you see what he does
no way he sets up these guys and you're
like the Joker that's the Joker that I
remember in the comics yeah it was a
darker joke and I remember really
feeling joke yeah this guy was it look
this guy was intense he had a lot of
problems but like Michael Caine famously
says we don't know what's wrong with
this guy some people just want to watch
the world burn particularly a world that
has Batman in it Christian Bale in this
movie this is the first time I really
noticed the Batman voice I was in the
theater watching next to you and he
comes into the back of the beginning and
he does the I'm not wearing hockey pads
and I'm like wow this guy's really
straight yeah and you know and that's
the thing though is that this movie was
there was such a story and a
through-line to it of what the Joker was
trying to prove and what Batman was
ultimately trying to prove and then you
had Harvey Dent and how it all played in
it just worked so magically and the fact
you got rid of Katie Holmes and brought
in Maggie Gyllenhaal and that you know
and she worked as Rachel and I mean
everything just worry works so well it's
such a crafted well-crafted story and I
mean I love this movie it's what it
really is it's fantastic
like in my swing
the really only problem I have this
movie is that like it like any great
comic or movie or music it has to follow
itself because it's so riveting for so
long and then you also have to rap over
them with Harvey Dent and you're like
man this is great but I still kind of
want to see anything else that you would
have with the Joker but that's not I
mean you can't really fault them Louie
for that because it was so good the
action scenes are so intense
they're filmed so dramatically it's such
an engaging film to watch I love this
movie it's all about the Joker really
causing mayhem on Gotham and making
people go to a dark place and showing
society that they don't have to go by
the rules that are that are set out
there and one of the things there was a
comment that I like to addressed in one
of our reviews is someone said well you
know Christian you said that the Joker
and Batman it's all about him it's all
about the Joker in this one it's not
it's the Joker that really runs the
story and he find they focus a lot on
him but it's not the Joker's origin
story and why he's the Joker and it's
not following him it's about the Joker
is the catalyst of what all this is
going down but it's Batman how I mean I
just I just love this movie so much I
can talk about it for three hours well
unfortunately I don't have that kind of
time thank goodness so we're going to
show this movie and again this is right
up there with Batman Begins I like bat
anythig ins a little bit more of us not
the fault of the Dark Knight so I'm
gonna give this one five out of five
smooth okay you gave a five out of five
I'm like if you cuz you're gonna have
another kid at some points you're gonna
have to you you're gonna love both of
them but you're gonna have one you like
better all right look at that and you
know the thing is - of this movie you
forget we didn't mention the IMAX they
shot a scene in IMAX s you know it's the
beginning of the unknown experience in
IMAX which also worked great visually
stunning great fantastic movie five out
of five I love it if you're surprised I
gave it five out of five to say you
don't have to say anything just put this
up and go to bed that's my
on that face
so we're the schmoes and we'll have to
say thank you for Chris Tuchman for
being a part of our series for having us
on his channel for being on our channel
make sure you check out very soon on
both our channel and Chris's channel of
separate reviews of the Dark Knight
Returns Rises he's rising he's probably
returning to but I talk about how much I
love it I call it returns the Dark
Knight does return but he's rising while
the returns how you like that bitches is
he giving revenge to table fuel thanks
Moses it was great doing this with you
guys - I look forward to more
collaborations in the future if you guys
haven't checked them out go over their
channel and give them a look they are
great they have great reviews and as
they said both of us will have separate
reviews for The Dark Knight Rises on
both of our channels pretty soon and I
also want to make a lot of people have
mentioned Batman mask of the phantasm
excellent movie yes it was theatrical
I'm aware of that excellent movie I have
a segment on my channel it fits that
movie perfectly I do overlooked reviews
I'm going to do a overlooked review for
mask of the phantasm in the next few
weeks look forward to that until next
time if you like this review you can
subscribe to my channel I get stuck my
god
Oh